Elon Musk taking his battle for free
speech right to the woke workers of
Twitter the world's richest man will be
speaking to Twitter employees at a town
hall this week it's the first time since
he agreed to a 44 billion dollar buyout
it's no secret the liberals who work
there have been trying to sabotage musk
and his plans to crack down on
censorship Twitter employees previously
complained that musk ruined their calm
Focus week
very sad I tell you Greg very sad for
these Twitter employees Elon Musk coming
in upping the price of the of the stock
and they're disappointed do you think
they need a crying room yeah you know
here's my prediction the employees that
are most angry will talk about the
hypothetical harm they experience from
words and ideas right that this is
actually creating an unsafe environment
that's why they wanted to ban Libs of
tick tock because he exposed like the
the kind of the madness uh the madness
and extremes of gender trans activism
and and what teachers were actually
telling the kids in schools and that for
them they think is unsafe and harmful
because it actually it actually kind of
reveals some ideologies something is
afoot though it's not just about Twitter
it's about what musk is part of and
maybe he's inspiring other companies to
do the same thing but it seems like
their adults returning from vacation to
take to tell the kids to go upstairs and
eat their freaking vegetables look at
Netflix putting the foot their foot down
Gadget newspapers removing their
opinions wapo firing that one uh
bad-mouthing wokester uh and and all of
this is kind of happening at the same
time and I do think that we are suddenly
discovering that the toxic toxic
identity politics that has showed up and
bubbled up an area didn't die in Con on
campus it infiltrated the real world and
it's just and it's migrating and I think
now we're finally getting to the point
where we're stopping it we found our
limits you know Dana it Greg makes a
terrific point and it's expected that
employees may also ask musk about his
plans for workplace culture the option
to work from home uh and so that's going
to go over real well yeah well that's
going to go over real well a couple of
things first of all I hope that bus
didn't schedule this on a day of rest
for the Twitter employees which they
often get that's also called Sunday in
most places
um this is what I would recommend to all
these employees keep an open mind
he he has an open mind do you have an
idea on how you want to improve Twitter
now if it includes censoring people yeah
that's not going to fly but you never
know like Elon Musk might like your idea
or he might surprise you he might turn
out to be the best boss you ever had so
I would love to be a fly on the wall of
the fly again it flies on your wall all
right Geraldo let's say you you know uh
I I think that
the the big issues of freedom of speech
and uh you know what what is permissible
uh in that the angle of uh of the
Twitter takes and all that will be
subordinate to the only issue on the
minds of those people right now I
believe is whether or not mouth school
go through with this deal he's he's been
uh he's been I almost used a a bad word
to describe he's been you know teasing
them and teasing them and giving me more
on your Bots give me more on the uh you
know the title to that information to
determine whether or not that they have
as many followers as they say they do he
is totally and and that's why they're so
nervous I believe that they're the real
anxiety these people are feeling isn't
that their free speech will be infringed
it is that he won't take over Twitter so
it'll be wounded by the fact that he
teased them and then they set them up
and now the secret is not as valuable as
it was before uh musk arrived and gave
it that juice but I I think that that
they're mostly concerned now with their
jobs as what about the possibility Jesse
of Twitter misrepresenting itself
there's a high probability that's the
case and he's going to have to do his
due diligence and figure out if they're
being fallacious or not but I don't know
if Greg's heard this phrase before
it's a saying yeah you never get a
second chance to make a first impression
and so you don't want anybody get off on
the wrong foot with your boss who
happens to be a billionaire and a genius
so don't go out there and peacock around
and show how woke you are to your
colleagues maybe be humble take a deep
breath you might actually learn
something as Dana said from Elon Musk
when I was given the seven I called all
the smartest most successful people in
the TV business you didn't call me no
all right wow
we're getting off on the wrong foot and
I asked them you know what was your
advice what was your I called people
outside the business Bob Costas Sports
guy is probably going to ruin his
reputation and I'm announcing that I
called him and they all said the same
thing they said listen listening is the
key and if these new employees would
just listen to this guy he's actually
pretty goddamn inspiring so just listen
to him and see how it goes okay you're
gonna have to apologize what did I say
all right nothing to do
I'm sorry for I don't know sorry God
okay ahead could Johnny Depp Sue Amber
Heard again the actress doubling down on
the accusations that got her taken to
court in the first place I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now